triangles or degree distribution which
are fairly easy to model and fill with
but we would try to compute something
that is very global and depend on the
link structure of the graph like easy
candy that is the distance distribution
so how many nodes are exactly distance D
and another thing we are interested in
is to try to understand which nodes are
important in some sense which is of
course a very general announced pacified
problem hide of it so I'll try to be
more precise so first of all this is
really for real so you can if you're
interested in with this measurement you
can download the software implementing
the algorithm and talking about as part
of the way bruh framework and actually
they have been implemented in other
large-scale streaming and non streaming
or shared memory framework which I'm
very happy with and actually we were
able to run this on the whole facebook
graph using just a simple work station
which was very nice and this is the
price actually that Michael was talking
about we ended up in the New York Times
but just by your times got it wrong by
an off by one these are the degrees this
is the distance so the paper is four
degrees of separation and no we are not
crazy we do not approximate 474 2 for
the degrees are 374 so the paper is four
degrees of separation okay just do oh
you're crazy Italian guy they
approximate 474 wheels okay so our first
motivation is I said is that we judged
the goodness of models for network using
local first order statistics and well we
have now acknowledged to generate more
or less everything like we want the
distribution asserted tivity and so on
so we will try to get something a little
bit more global like the distance
distribution of the harmonic diameter
which is the harmonic mean of all
distances including infinite which is
very important when to you when you may
just stuff like the web in which a lot
of node actually a pair of nodes are
actually unreachable because it is that
if you know something about it like this
about a network it will be somehow not
many more informative is too much it
will give you
very different source of information
about the network then say the degree
distribution okay because these drills
depend on how the network is
interconnected and not really just on
local properties now one thing we are
also our first motivation was actually
that one global property people use is
the diameter all the average distance or
something like that but that's very
difficult to judge because then you say
something like you know okay social
network ever look like Nick logarithmic
diameter look at it pick me there is a
big ol mean that there is a constant
means that when you are the data set and
you get 33 what does it mean 3333 I mean
if you don't have constants we cannot
judge anything so we try to fiddle with
some more statistics and the idea was ok
let's look at the dispersion of the
distribution the variance to me ratio of
the distance distribution of drafts and
ok this is a standard somehow terms
under one is under the spirit over one
is over dispersed and that is that web
browser and social networks are very
different with these aspects these are
web graphs are very size from 100,000 to
few billion nodes this is facebook and
these are very social network like or
kooter or hollywood and song so there is
clear a difference in the distance
distribution ok as we go on we measure
more networks and we we don't know why
theoretical theoretically tell it
happens I mean it would be very nice to
have two different models for web browse
and for social networks in which we can
prove that the distance distribution is
this different dispersion property but I
don't know of presently of any model
that does that a second motivation to do
this is geometric centrality so
geometric centrality zar though
centrality is that depend on the
distances on the graph not on spectral
theory like page rank or dominant eigen
vector not on the whole set of shortest
paths like between the centrality but
just on the distances and these are
actually the oldest ever defined
centrale use of this kind might be
familiar be avail as closeness 48 so
basically it is that you take the sum of
the distances to you if this is large or
peripheral because there are
those that are far from you and then you
take the reciprocal to have a central
tea growing with your growing with your
spirituality decreasing I mean auntie
monotone okay this is obviously a number
of problems if there are disconnected
path so if there are no such that D Y X
is infinity so what you can what people
do is to omit those notes but the result
is that is more components re the
advantage so we what really interested
in is harmonic centrality which is a
very small change but actually is like
game changer change in the sense that
now you can put infinity here you get
zeros in the sun and this works on a
network them in this very is very good
results on the web or in general network
that I've disconnect luck so we would
like to estimate this on very large
networks and of course we don't want to
do and breadth first visits to do this
because that would be very difficult
like on facebook notice that
mathematically is like the reciprocal of
a de normalized average and this is the
reciprocal the reciprocal of a de
normalized harmonic mean so from here to
here is just moving from the arithmetic
mean to the harmonic mean which is a
general trending this network starting
with mercury notorious paper in two
thousand harmony with the small world
which suggested that in general when
you're disconnected pairs is better to
move from average of Maxima or Maxima to
harmonic means ok these are second
motivation I'll try to try just how to
treat a little bit with a so this is the
first eight nodes of the Hollywood
co-citation network by page rank okay
this is a very famous porn actor as you
don't know and so we we are not so
satisfied with these results as you can
easily imagine because there are number
of people we would not like to begin if
you take between this yeah yeah probably
also here that are quite a number of
result we are not so happy with harmonic
centrality is definitely a more
realistic picture what's in Hollywood
now so this is very neg natale if you're
interested there are a bunch of more
mathematical evaluation of these
instances it tells you that harmonic
actually
give you a very good signal but Jesus
does the trick I mean we we really like
to compute harmonic centrality on very
large graphs okay so what we do how do
you do this okay there is an
intermediate step in which actually what
to do with what we do is we compute for
each node of the graph we complete the
sequence the number of nodes a distance
exactly t okay and I will briefly
explain how we do it because this is the
part that we cannot really explain well
so for instance if you add up over all
notes for each t you get the numerosity
of nodes of distance e which modular
normalization gives you the distance
distribution so if you can know this for
HD in sequence you can print the
distance distribution nice but you can
also do other things like a central it
is because the formula I shown you can
be easily written in a different way so
this is just harmonic centrality but
instead of ending the reciprocal of the
distances I count the number of distance
tea and multiply this by 1 over T this
is a just a different way of writing up
that some okay instead I count 1 the
node distance one then I wait one half
of the notes distance two and then one
third the nose of this top three and so
on but the next thing of this is that I
just have to know this number in
sequence for every T and accumulate the
result so if I can enumerate for each
node the number of know the distance t2x
is very easy by keeping track with a
single floating point per node of this
summation and in the end you will get a
harmonic centrality so these are the two
things we are you really interested in
distributions and harmonics it went okay
how do you do this the basic idea is
come from a paper that is now with 11
years actually the field in some
previous paper but it up in a very
hidden form so it is to this dynamic
program so let btx be the bowl of radio
state t around X so distance add nodes
at masti from X note that when talking
about centrality we want the incoming
path so you will have to apply all these
to the transpose graph
on saying any more about this in a word
files so clearly the ball of radius 0 is
just X but the nice thing is that you
can compute any ball just by dynamic
programming if you know the smaller
balls so the notes that are within
distance D plus 1 from eggs are x and
the nodes a distance at most t from each
of you of neighbors okay because if i
can go from X to Y in T plus 1 steps I
must have done one step to get a
neighbor and then at masti steps so we
can just you know start from this and
iteratively compute this which is very
nice for a number of reasons for first
of all this competition is very highly
parallelizable because it's independent
for each be three plus one certainly can
be done just by enumerated the edges XY
lexicographical order so it's almost
streaming on disk you don't really need
to keep the graph in memory so there are
a number of ways way this works very
very well the obvious okk once we have
this in sequence we can just take these
differences and this will be our nodes
at distance D so we want to compute
balls because we want to know the size
of the balls because we want to take
differences because this will give us
the number of nodes at distance D and
from the know the distance see we can do
this on distributions we can do harmonic
centrality and a lot of ethics now the
somehow this problem is that these they
are expensive because each set uses
linear space it would be quadratic in
size of so we cannot really do it so
what we do is actually we use a
approximate set with some objects called
probability counters which are so rough
such rough representation of a set that
actually the only answer can give they
can give you somehow reality is the size
of the set nothing more you cannot you
cannot really ask which elements are in
the set and hmm they are very very small
but the main point is that we need the
such an approach we need okay this is
not really English we need an
approximation of this kind from which we
can compute the union's quickly so we
will never keep an explicit represent
explicit represent
these balls we will just have this very
small log log and bit probabilistic
counters that will be combined doing
unions and okay now this will be so
statistical graphs that someone will
probably have some problem at the store
but it's just as like this tries to give
the idea so the idea of these counters
which were developed by flash relay and
in school and have widely used in the
industry you can find papers about that
from google or from aggregate knowledge
and so on it's just that instead of we
see a stream of elements one by one but
instead of keeping track of the set we
keep keep track of a very simple feature
of the set and the feature is computed
in this way we take the number of
training zero of a very good function as
function applied to each element of the
set let me take the maximum so that is
that if you see very few elements your
hands function we give you mostly odd
values and you get zero but if you start
to see many elements you will start to
see something that is divided by x 4 by
8 and this maximum raise would rise ok
essentially what you do is to keep the
track maximum of the OM and you can show
that X essentially log log and beats ok
great a sufficient and ok this is very
bad because these this process doesn't
even have a finite expected value but
basically what you get is that the
number of distinct element you've seen
our 2 to the power of M there are a
number of very huge number of things you
can do to make this work like to have
multiple counters to decrease variance
use must you harmonic mean I mean there
is a very nice paper by flood across
three paper buy flagyl about this but
the nice thing of this process is that
the counter associated to a stream a
combined stream is just the maximal on
the two counters so if I see a stream a
extremely I get to number five and seven
what would be the number associated to a
and B in sequence the maximum of five
and seven so it's very very easy to
compute Union in these very approximate
representation is just maximum so what
we do is actually keep in memory track
of the ball of radius T uses
there is very very simple sketch okay
and then we go all computing maxima
basically which will give us the bowl of
larger radius and okay these are example
how convergence works so depending on
how much memory you use this counter
have a guaranteed relative standard
deviation or relative coefficient of
variation our going to call it and
depending on how this is the standard
error curve how many trials you do take
an average this is improves so this is
the theoretical precision relative
precision of each counter okay now I've
told you that we do a number of things
we take differences will write / t blah
blah then we gather up and we these are
the statistics of the actual error
computer than a small graph so we could
have exact values of armonyx and rightly
so you see that practically what happens
is that harmonic centrality converges
even better then the theory would say of
each single cut so this is the average
relative error the usual box plot I mean
quartile for tile average plus minus
standard deviation so what happens is
that we have discounters we have a
theoretical guaranteed precision
actually get something better when you
aggregate the data but now the point is
that this is nice but it shouldn't
really happen so it shouldn't really
happen because we're taking differences
and we have a relative standard error or
guarantee so when we are say at the end
of the computation and a bowl is 1
billion nodes and the next more note is
1 billion plus 1 nodes we are estimating
one the difference between the two balls
but we have two estimators from the 1
billion node and then 1 billion plus 1
both there are ten percent wrong and
when you take differences there is no
way to guarantee that this is these two
error combine well so your error is
about order 1 million and you're
estimating one it shouldn't work in
theory but when you try to check against
the ground truth actually works and
everybody is doing this just to say I'm
not the crazy guy I mean
everybody is actually doing this but the
basic problem here is that you cannot
take the difference of two estimators
with a ballad rsd and get an estimator
with a bounded rsb you get the sum of
two positive estimator with a bounded
rsd and get the same rsd but you cannot
take the differences nonetheless we
observe very good convergence of every
small network for which we can actually
have different mean exhausted metal
computation like the graphic showing you
is on Wikipedia is 5 million nodes it's
like one week of parallel competition on
a nice work rotation you can get exact
harmonics and travel t or if you have a
billion and node mpi cluster probably
you can do better but we don't have it
this might be related to the fact that
there is some very defeated connection
between the balls I mean there is the
graph structure in between I mean the
dis bolas not these balls are not
completely random pieces of it from
information they're extremely dependent
so on one side the dependency makes it
difficult to do statistical analysis on
the other hand we know a lot of how this
ball evolved during the computation okay
and so maybe it's just a general
statistic a phenomenal you are great a
lot of data that I'm error in all
direction and then you get something
better first of all I want to make very
clear there I'm an algorithm guy I've
very little feel for statistics I mean
my gut feeling for statistics statistics
usually wrong so I'm very interested in
getting people interested in this
problem because I will never publish a
paper about that but I would like to
know why what we're doing actually
appears to work okay there is an easy
observation you can do based on the
graph structure there is a three-phase
evolution of the computation so
basically what happens is that at the
start you have the graph and the balls
are very small ok radius one or two this
balls basically are independent
estimator because there is no
intersection so from the point of view
of the estimator
just reducing not increasing the rsd
because you have 1,000,000,000
completely independent estimators so the
fact that on the very first phrases of
the computation everything works is not
so weird because we're is somehow
exploding the fact that until this ball
get to the point where they start to
intersect significantly basically we are
just doing independent estimation so at
some point both start to intersect so we
start to get dependency but what happens
is that at least for the distance
distribution but the phenomenon
transfers to then we are in the peak of
the distribution now for the network we
study the peak of the distribution is of
the order point 1.2 elites a lot of
probability mass and the error we get
the relative error we get is like 100 1
person sorry so if when one person
relative error translate to 1 over 100
absolute error when you take differences
not bad I mean yeah okay here we don't
really know what's happening it's a mess
but the relative do we get the absolute
error we get is good ok so i expend you
I just will hum hang some hand waving I
believe this part works and then that is
the tail the tail is very interesting
because something happens everything
becomes totally dependent I mean when
you we are in the tail here let me do it
with the CDF because it is clear so we
are doing something like this ok in the
very last phases this will change very
little so they are almost identical one
another so the error is old all on one
side because the arrow depend on the
actual site that is in the counter and
when you are just in the final part you
know like I'm I'm getting this and just
a little bit more at each step this the
elements had seen it booting the set
move the arrow completely towards a
single direction like minus ten percent
and all the successive value will get
empirically at exactly the same error so
when you take two estimators that that
exactly the same error in practice well
these are
there are transfers to the difference
and this is why even if it's completely
crazy we get extremely precise
estimations here but again it's
completely crazy because we have our
actual terror is 1 million we're
estimating one okay so this is the best
I can say about how I bill why you leave
this is actually working so well but it
would be very nice to have either some
combined statistical graph theory
explanation of this or some general
statistical analysis of the phenomenon
notice that we actually just working
eventually I one thing when we have real
examples of networks in which is this
vision is not so piqued which is like
something like that like road networks
and series we're really we see from real
exact exact computation to approximate
computation a big mistake I mean we see
the actual absolute error coming in and
you get something like this instead of
what you want so it appears that at
least the middle phase can be wrong as
much as the absolute error the other two
does not seem to be so wrong but maybe
because of this phenomenon I'm always
pushing the leak the graph structure you
try to advise to every trainee grass or
where the shitty graph is they are loved
SF diameter too so there is not very I
mean in torrance way over yeah we try to
what we run this of course to check
whether the speed was correct like in an
approximate in a a preferential
attachment model set or a douche remodel
we tried to run these or large graphs
but the problem is that everything
converges like in six steps so if you
should drive in worse chromatographs of
stuff like that it's two steps so it's
absolutely unrealistic and it's very
difficult to get any otherwise you must
put down the coin toss of the artist
early model elder Sony models so low
that you get a very disconnected graph
and again you're going to get much
information because there is no
dependence at that point so it's even
very difficult to tune the parameter
of the but yeah I mean what we try to do
was to get to an algebra of breaths in
which if you know the explicitly the cdf
of the two pieces you can compute
directly the cdf of the combination you
can do it for me very simple graph
operation like related protocol product
but then it becomes completely
impossible once you start to overlap
because in this way we call them have
the possibility of generative of a
heading explicitly the cdf of very large
graphs which very rarely is known but
then we got against some wall and then
we stopped basically thank